cuando estamos trabajando con aritmética
básica generalmente sabemos exactamente
con qué números estamos trabajando
tenemos 23 más 5 y haciendo esa suma nos
quedan 28 o tenemos 7 por 3 o tenemos
110 entre 11 pero bueno el chiste es que
aquí sabemos con qué números estamos
trabajando 23 528 73 110 11 sin embargo
conforme nos vamos metiendo al mundo
algebraico nos vamos encontrando con
cosas un poquito más abstractas digamos
seguramente ya te has encontrado con
algunas de estas estas variables
y estas variables ya no son números
fijos a estas variables pues las puedes
ver de un montón de formas pero lo más
importante es que estas variables pueden
cambiar sus valores o sea sus valores no
están fijos no son exactamente 110 ni
siete ni cinco no está perfectamente
determinado cuánto vale a ver veamos un
ejemplo por ejemplo x + 5 aunque esto de
aquí todo esto junto es una expresión y
la variable en esta expresión es esta es
x x en nuestra variable y cuanto vale x
depende del contexto no está algo fijo y
por lo tanto cuanto vale x + 5 tampoco
es algo fijo por ejemplo si nosotros
decimos que x es igual a 1
x es igual a 1 entonces
x + 5 es igual a ver aquí tenemos que la
equis vale 1 entonces x 5 vale 15 y eso
es igual a 6
ahora la x no tiene por qué siempre ser
igual a 1 aunque yo aquí estábamos en un
escenario en un contexto en el que la x
era igual a 1 sin embargo también podría
hacer que la x fuera igual a nose menos
7 aunque vamos a ver qué pasa en este
caso
x es igual a menos 7 entonces
x + 5 pues aquí la equis esta x vale en
este contexto en el que x vale menos
siete pues vale menos 7
así es que x 5 es igual a menos 75 menos
siete más 5 lo cual es igual a menos 2
aunque yo entonces este es un muy buen
ejemplo de cómo la variable x
dependiendo del contexto puede tener
distintos valores que hay entonces ya
vimos las variables dentro de
expresiones pero las variables también
los podemos encontrar en las ecuaciones
ahora hay que notar es muy importante
notar que las expresiones son distintas
de las ecuaciones acá y las expresiones
son simplemente así un conjunto de
símbolos que no tienen igual que
simplemente expresan un valor aunque
aunque no esté fijo ese valor a ver por
aquí pongamos expresiones
un mes
ok las expresiones expresan cierto valor
un ejemplo de una expresión es como el
que ya vimos x + 5 donde pues podemos
sustituir el valor de esta variable como
lo hicimos aquí y dependiendo del valor
que tome esta variable
la expresión va a tomar cierto valor o
sea en este caso tomó el valor de 6
luego en este caso tomó el valor de
menos 2 el chiste es que el valor de la
expresión cambia cuando cambia el valor
de la variable aunque hay pero este no
es el único tipo de expresiones también
podemos tener una expresión que sea como
ye más
zeta donde no hay ni un solo número fijo
aquí todavía tenemos el 5 pero aquí
estas dos son variables no fijas y
podemos sustituir a cada una de ellas
con distintos números si ya es 1 762
entonces esta expresión va a ser uno más
2 si por ejemplo ahora es igual a 0
iceta es igual a menos 1 entonces éste
va a ser igual a 0 1 entonces las
expresiones expresan un valor a
diferencia de las ecuaciones las
ecuaciones lo que hacen es tomar
expresiones y igualar las a otras
expresiones las ecuaciones lo que van a
hacer es tomar un signo de igual y poner
una expresión de este lado y otra
expresión de este lado ok entonces lo
que hacen las ecuaciones es decirnos que
estas dos expresiones son iguales
entonces tenemos aquí a las ecuaciones
que lo que hacen es tomar una expresión
un ejemplo de una expresión es x + 3 y
igualarlo a otra expresión que esta
expresión podría ser por ejemplo un 1
ésta también es una expresión hay
algunos casos como éste donde la
ecuación empieza a restringir qué
valores pueden tomar sus variables ok
por ejemplo si tenemos una sola ecuación
tenemos una sola variable dentro de la
ecuación entonces aquí ya sabemos
exactamente cuánto tiene que valer la
equis para que se dé esta igualdad aquí
de hecho seguramente lo puedes hacer en
tu cabeza qué cosa si le sumas 3 te da 1
pues menos dos si le sumas tres de 17 y
además es el único número que hace eso
ok entonces nosotros sabemos que esta
variable tiene que valer menos 2 aunque
hay entonces la ecuación esta ecuación
este signo de igual está restringiendo
los valores que puede tomar esta
variable sin embargo no todas las
ecuaciones nos pueden decir exactamente
cuánto tienen que valer las variables
que se encuentran en sus expresiones
aunque hay por ejemplo también podemos
tener la expresión x más una zeta esto
es una expresión igualada a otra
expresión como por ejemplo 5 también es
una expresión y esta ecuación no obliga
a cada una de sus variables a tomar un
solo valor este es el ejemplo de una
ecuación que no obliga a sus variables a
tomar un valor fijo determinado aquí
nosotros no podemos decir directamente
cuánto tiene que valer la equis
en cuanto tienen que valer la zeta
ahora aunque esta ecuación no determine
exactamente cuánto tienen que valer
estas variables si las restringe un
poquito pero las restringe con respecto
a lo que valen las otras variables
aunque por ejemplo si nosotros sabemos
cuánto vale oye y cuánto vale z entonces
ya podemos determinar exactamente cuánto
vale x ok a ver
y que es igual a 3 y se está aquí vamos
a poner una coma para denotar el y
porque si pongo un y va a aparecer una y
pero no y z es igual a 2 aunque entonces
aquí nosotros tenemos que esto es igual
a 13 y esto es igual a 12 al menos en
este contexto tres más dos es un 5
entonces esta ecuación es igual
es más 5 es igual a 5 ok entonces
podemos hacer esta cuenta en nuestra
cabeza y nosotros sabemos que entonces
esto implica que x es igual a 0 ok
entonces esta ecuación en este contexto
en el que ya es igual a 3 y 7 es igual a
2 implica este símbolo es el símbolo de
implica significa más o menos un
entonces pero bueno si tenemos esta
ecuación y este contexto entonces x
tiene que ser exactamente igual a 0 pero
bueno aquí hay dos puntos muy
importantes uno es que las expresiones
son distintas de las ecuaciones y esta
es una expresión y las ecuaciones son la
igualdad entre dos expresiones ok este
es el primer punto el segundo punto es
que las variables pueden tomar
muchísimos valores distintos ok y
dependiendo del contexto en el que se
encuentren pueden tomar un valor pueden
tomar algún otro
pueden no estar restringidas y pueden a
fuerzas tener que ser iguales a cierto
valor pero el chiste es que en general
no está fijo cuál es el valor que tienen
que tomar o al menos todavía no sabemos
cuál es el valor que tienen que tomar
okay bueno entonces para recalcar esto
de que las variables pueden tomar muchos
valores vamos a evaluar un montón de
expresiones con distintos valores de
alguna variable
entonces por ejemplo podemos tener la
expresión x a la ye y x por ejemplo
puede valer 5 mientras que puede darse
el caso de que lleva ya tres cierto aquí
no tenemos ninguna restricción con
respecto a cuánto pueden valer estas
variables así es que escogemos dos
números en este caso yo escogí cinco y
tres y vamos a evaluar esta expresión
cuando la variable x que no
necesariamente tiene que ser igual a 5
pero en este contexto x va a ser igual a
5 y en este contexto va a ser igual a 3
y entonces evaluando esta expresión
en este contexto nosotros lo que tenemos
5 elevado a la 3 que y eso es
simplemente 5 x 5 x 5 5 x 5 x 5 que es
igual a 125 aunque entonces vamos a
poner otro contexto tenemos la misma
expresión pero ahora vamos a ver el
contexto donde x es igual a menos 2 y
que es igual a pues digamos que es igual
a 2 también aunque entonces lo que
tenemos aquí es que pues x es igual a
menos 2 entonces tenemos por aquí un -2
y tenemos que elevar a la equis que es
esta x la tenemos que elevar a la
potencia pero que es igual a 2 entonces
aquí tenemos 12
y esto es igual a menos 2 x menos 2 -
por menos nos da más y 2 x 2 nos da
cuatro así es que esto es igual a 4 pero
también podemos tener expresiones mucho
más complicadas por ejemplo podemos
tener la raíz cuadrada de
x + y - x les parece una expresión
complicada y entonces podemos evaluar
esta expresión cuando la variable x es
igual a 1 y la variable que es igual a
no se digamos 8 entonces sabemos que la
x puede ser cualquier otro número pero
escogimos el 1 y que la ye puede ser
cualquier otro número pero escogimos el
8 y entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
cada vez que encontremos una x en esta
expresión la banza sustituir por un 1 y
aquí tenemos un 1 este ya lo aquí
tenemos otra vez otra x entonces esto
tiene que ser otro 1 y cada vez que
veamos una ya la tenemos que sustituir
por un 8 aunque entonces está allí es un
8 y entonces lo que tenemos es la raíz
cuadrada de 1 más
8 - 11 + 8 9 entonces su raíz cuadrada
es 33 menos uno es 2 así es que esta
expresión es igualdad